in this section, we are going to look at
the
mathematical way
Of using the Bayesian theorem.
specifically the algebraic way
of using the different terms.
In the Bayesian theorem, which is
an extension of conditional probability.
and then
the intuition
so as opposed to Simply plugging in numbers.
We want to understand why the terms
are arranged the way they are
arranged.
The first thing we'll do is look at
deriving the business theorem. So we will go
from conditional probability to the Bayesian
theorem.
And then once we have you know.
Done this algebraically we understand how and
why we have this particular expression.
We will then turn.
to an example
as specifically we want to talk about
three key terms
in
Bayesian probability
and these three terms are the prior.
likelihood
and the posterior
now the way these two equations differ.
Is in the denominator?
at the right side of the equal sign so in this
Form we have the sum.
of the joint probabilities
In the second one, we have simply the
marginal probability in the denominator.
You don't have to know the meaning of these words just yet.
Because that's what we're going to cover next. We're going to go over
a number of terms with first go over.
Probability which you already know what that is,
but we'll review it anyway.
Then we'll talk about marginal and Joint probabilities
and once we've established these.
We can go back.
derive
the busy in theorem to formula for
the Bayesian theorem
and then continue on to talk about terms that
apply specifically in the
Bayesian context.
so the words like
prior
likelihood and posterior
now, of course before we can talk about prior and likelihood
the product of which will give us the posterior.
We will also first talk about odds, which
is the ratio of two.
marginal or joint probabilities
so again a lot of terminology, but
we are about to now Define these terms.